BRIAN WRITES THE BOOKS THAT MAK
YOU THINK WHAT'S ON TV.
ANYWAY, THIS MONOLOGUE HAS BEEN
ABOUT BRIAN.
WHAT ABOUT THE SUPREME COURT
HEARINGS, BUT THAT IS A DONE
DEAL.
BUT IT GAVE US ONE NUGGET.
>> CAN YOU DEFINE --
PROVIDE A DEFINITION FOR THE
WORD WOMAN.
>> I CAN'T.
>> YOU CAN'T?
>> NOT IN THIS CONTEST.
>> THAT SHOULDN'T BE A TOUGH
QUESTION TO ANSWER.
IF SOMEBODY ASKED ME, HEY, GREAT
, WHAT IS A WOMAN, I WOULD
SHOW THEM THIS PICTURE.
SHE STILL MAKES ME TINGLE.
BUT WHY WAS AT THE HEART FOR A
JUDGE TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION,
BECAUSE WE LET THE BULK TAKE TH
SIMPLEST OF LIFE AND EXPLOITED.
IT IS PART OF THE TRIFECTA BACK
GREAT NEW REASON TO CALL PEOPLE
BIGOTS AND GIVE COLLEGE
PROFESSOR SOMETHING TO WASTE
TIME ON.
USA TODAY CAME TO JACKSON'S
DEFENSE BUT TOTALLY SCREWED IT
UP USING NOTHING BUT GENDER
STUDIES SCHOLARS.
THERE ARE SCHOLARS IN GENDER
STUDIES.
THAT IS LIKE BEING A TALL
MUNCHKIN.
AND THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
SECTION IRONICALLY, THE HEADLIN
READS MARSHA BLACKBURN ASKED
KETANJI BROWN JACKSON TO DEFINE
WOMEN.
THE SIGN SAYS THERE'S NO SIMPLE
ANSWER.
THE SAME FOLKS WHO CAME UP WITH
THE PHRASE FOLLOW THE SIGNS THA
IGNORE THEIR OWN ADVICE WHEN IT
IS A BENEFIT THERE POLITICS SO
GUESS WE CAN'T CALL JACKSON THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE BECAUSE, ACCORDING TO
THEM, SHE MIGHT NOT BE A WOMAN
BUT IN REALITY WHAT IS FEMA HAS
BEEN A SIMPLE QUESTION FOR THE
300,000 YEARS HUMANS HAVE
EXISTED.
IT'S ONLY IN THE LAST DECADE
THAT IDIOTS HAVE TURNED IT INTO
A TRICK QUESTION ON A BIOLOGY
TEST.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY PREFER IDEOLOGY
OVER BIOLOGY.
SO THERE IS NO WAY TO CLEARLY
DEFINE WHAT MAKES SOMEONE A
WOMAN.
I'VE GOT AN IDEA TO PUT THIS
DEBATE TO REST.
ASK 100 MEN OFF THE STREET.
THEY WILL DEFINE A WOMAN AS A
HUMAN BEING WHO HAS A NURTURING
SIDE WHO CAN BE EMOTIONALLY
STRONG AS A BALL, WHO WILL
ALWAYS HAVE YOUR BACK FOREVER,
AND MAYBE THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
CREATURES ON EARTH, BUT WHO
CAN'T PARALLEL PARK.
A SEXIST WOULD SAY BUT THIS IS
WORKING WITH SAY TODAY IS
SCREWED OUT.
THE INTERVIEWED ONLY GENDER
STUDY EXPERTS ON QUESTIONS OF
BIOLOGY.
THAT'S LIKE INTERVIEWING DATA
PERINO ON DEPTH METAL.
AND THEY ALSO JACKSON WAS WRONG
EVEN SITE BIOLOGY READ YOU THAT
JACKSON WAS WOKE, WHEN IT COMES
TO DEFINING A WOMAN COMPARING T
THESE ZOMBIES, SHE IS CLAY.
BUT THIS IS FROM THE FREAKS WHO
BROUGHT YOU TO PLUS TWO DOESN'T
HAVE TO EQUAL FOUR PERIODS OF
THE BELIEVE THE JUDGE PUNT THAT
BY REFERRING TO BIOLOGY.
ACCORDING TO YOUNG, THERE'S NOT
A BIOLOGICAL ANSWER TO WHAT IS
FEMALE.
SARAH RICHARDSON, ANOTHER GENDE
EXPERT, SAYS SIGNS CANNOT SETTL
ON OUR REALLY SOCIAL QUESTIONS.
SO YOUR IS SOCIAL AND NOT
BIOLOGICAL AND I THOUGHT BILL
CLINTON WAS 40 FOR TRYING TO
REDEFINE WHAT IS HE IS.
AND MALE PERVERTS CAN MOVE INTO
FEMALE PRISONS.
IT'S SEXIST JUST A SOCIAL THING
YOU CAN DO OR SAY ALMOST
ANYTHING.
THAT WAIT A FACT CHANGES FROM
WHAT IS TO WHAT PEOPLE SAY IT IS
.
AND BIOLOGY, WHICH IS BASED IN
ABSOLUTES, IS AN AS UNWELCOME A
KATIE AT A RALLY.
GINGER STUDIES OF LIKE ASTROLOGY
.
WITH ASTROLOGY YOU LOOK UP TO
THE SKIES AND MAKE UP STUFF.
WITH GENDER STUDY TO LOOK DOWN
IN THE LOCKER ROOM AND THEN DEN
REALITY.
WILLIAMS IS ANOTHER GENDER
EXPERT SAID WHITE'S PRIMACY DID
THAT TONIGHT THAT WOMEN OF COLO
FOR FEMALE.
WHEN YOU EMBRACE BIOLOGY THAT
REFUTES THAT?
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, YOU USIN
HORRIBLE RACISM TO JUSTIFY --
THAT LOGIC MOVES BACKWARDS
QUICKER THAN ME IN A RING WITH
TIRES.
THEY THEN DENY THE AUDI RE:
THOMAS, THE FRANCE SWIMMER WHO
IS SCREAMING SWIMMERS IN THE
POOL.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE ARE ASSIGNE
ME A WET BIRTH AND HAVE HIGHER
TESTOSTERONE LEVELS AND COULD
NEVER MAKE A DIVISION I SWIMMIN
TEAM.
5 DEGREES EQUATE HER SUCCESS TO
HER ASSIGNED RATHER THAN A LONG
RECORD AS ELITE SWIMMER.
WELL, YOU BUILT, BECAUSE SHE
WASN'T OKAY MALE SWIMMER THAT I
NOW BEATING OUTSTANDING FEMALE
SWIMMERS BE PRECISELY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MUSCLE MASS
THAT HER MALENESS GAVE HER, YOU
DON'T, SHE EQUATES ALL MALES NO
BEING SWIMMERS THAN ELITE WOMEN
WHO DENY THE FACT THAT A
MEDIOCRE MALE CAN DOMINATE THE
E-MAIL RACE.
HOW NUTS IS THAT.
AND PARK ME FOR SAYING NUTS.
I MEAN, THE KIND THAT SQUIRRELS
EAT.
THIS NONSENSE MAKES ME TEST THE.
I'M SORRY.
SO WHAT DEFINES A WOMAN?
IN THE ARTICLE THEY SAY
EMBRACING REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE,
FIGHTING THE INEQUALITY OF
INVESTMENT AND GIRLS SPORTS AND
WAY DISCRIMINATION.
AGAIN, IF NOT BIOLOGY, IT IS
IDEOLOGY, WHICH MEANS A FEMALE
CAN GO FOR WHOLE WIFE WITHOUT
BEING FEMA BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T
KNOW THE DOCTRINES OF GENDER
STUDIES GRADUATES.
THAT'S NOT BIOLOGY AND I SAY
THAT AS A PROUD WOMAN OF COLOR.
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GAS.
>> SHE'S DRY, LIFELESS, AND IN
DEUCE WITH THE HEAT RASH.
MOST OF --
HOST OF ONE NATION ON SATURDAY
NIGHT AT 8, BRIAN KILMEADE.
AND A SMATTERING OF APPLAUSE.
>> IT WAS THE BEST INTRODUCTION.
>> LIKE REDSKINS LYNX HAWTHORNE
IT, SHE IS CONSTANTLY PACKING.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KATIE
PAVLICH.
SHE IS LIKE MY REFRIGERATOR,
COLD AND EMPTY, EXCEPT FOR BEIN
HERE.
KAT TIMPF.
AND HIS SHOE SIZE IS A MINIVAN,
THE WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION
TYRUS.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, BRIAN.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME, I
GUESS.
I THINK THIS IS THE FOURTH SHOW
THAT YOU'VE DONE TODAY.
LET'S GET DOWN TO IT.
YOU ARE IN SPORTS.
HAVE YOU EVER CONSIDERED, DO YO
HAVE THE HIPS TO IDENTIFY AS A
WOMAN AND TRY OUT FOR THE GIRLS
OLYMPIC SOCCER TEAM BECAUSE YOU
LOVE SOCCER.
I THINK YOU COULD DO IT.
>> THINGS FOR BELIEVING IN ME.
I'M NOTICING MY HIPS BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN A GOAL OF MINE.
SO I THINK THAT WE ARE BEING
TROLLS.
I THINK THIS WHOLE CONVERSATION
IS SO OUT IN LEFT FIELD, LOOK A
THE STORY AND I HOPE IT GOES
AWAY BECAUSE I HATE BEING MEAN
TO PEOPLE, UNLIKE YOU, AND
THOMAS, SHE IS GETTING BOOED IN
THE POOL.
SHE'S ALREADY HAD PROBABLY A
CHALLENGING LIFE AND NOW SHE
WINS TOTAL SILENCE AND NOW SHE
COMES IN LAST THE REST OF THE
TOURNAMENT.
OBVIOUSLY THROWS IN THE STREET.
THE HARD THING IS IF YOU'RE
PUTTING DOWN AND IT'S OKAY BUT
WE ARE SAYING, OKAY, IT IS NOT
ABOUT ME.
IT IS ABOUT WOMEN SO IS UP THER
TO WOMEN.
THAT IS PEOPLE'S HEADS READY TO
EXPLODE AND WOMEN ARE SPEAKING
UP AND SAY IT'S NOT THERE TO MY
KID.
IT IS NOT FAIR TO ME THAT SHE I
BEATING NEED FOR SIX MONTHS AGO
SHE WAS A MAN BEATING ME AND NO
SHE IS A WOMAN AND I DON'T THIN
I MADE ANY SENSE.
>> I HATE GETTING BOOED AT THE
POOL.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO PUT IN AN EXTR
BATHROOM.
>> NEVER HAVE CHILLY BEFORE YOU
SWIM.
>> NO ONE COMING INTO THE PORT
PROBLEMS SIZE.
BRIGHTEST EVER SEEN ONE OUTSIDE
"FOX & FRIENDS".
I DON'T KNOW WHAT A WOMAN IS.
IT'S TOTALLY FINE.
SCIENTIFICALLY A WOMAN IS A
HUMAN BEING, WHICH SOME ADULT.
AND TO PUT IT I'M REALLY GLAD A
JUDGE WITNESS SOMETHING THAT
COMPLICATED, LIKE THAT.
IF YOU CAN'T FIND A WOMAN,
HEARTIEST LOOK AT THE LAW AND
INTO HER.
MORE COMPLICATED ISSUES WHEN
WOMEN ARE DEEPLY EMBEDDED BUT I
COMES TO THE ISSUE OF PORTION O
TITLE 9.
ONE THING I WANT TO SAY ABOUT
LIA THOMAS, A YEAR OF AGO SHE
WAS HOLDING ON THE MEN'S TEAM S
THIS IS NOT LIKE A LIFELONG
SITUATION HERE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT?
>> ABOUT WOMEN?
>> WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
WHY ARE THERE SO MANY WOMEN ON
THE SET.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW, SHE CAN
DISTORT YOU, MAN.
WE GOT TO GO GET SOME BEERS
AFTERWARD.
>> AND FIND OUT WHAT A WOMAN
REALLY IS.
>> Greg: I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> AND WE NEVER WILL.
>> Greg: NO, WE WON'T.
YOU KNOW, KAT, I'D YOU SURPRISE
THAT THERE WEREN'T THAT MANY
GENDER STUDY EXPERTS TO BE
INTERVIEWED.
IT SEEMS LIKE ALL OF THEM, ALL
THEY DO IS GET INTERVIEWED BY
REPORTERS.
THEY ARE NOT LIKE ICU NURSES.
I'M SURE THAT THEY WERE
AVAILABLE BY THE CALL WHENEVER.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
I THINK THAT MEANS THAT USA
TODAY MIGHT'VE HAD AN ULTERIOR
MOTIVE AND I THINK THE REASON
WHY, IT UPSET CONSERVATIVES AND
OBVIOUS REASONS AND THEN THE
STUDIES WERE ALSO UPSET BECAUSE
SHE BROUGHT BIOLOGY INTO IT.
AND THE REASON WHY UP WAS
BECAUSE WAS TERRIFIED.
WHICH I ADMIT BEFORE, WHENEVER
I'M ASKED GENDER HIM EVEN NOR D
A GENDER, UNLIKE DANGER, DANGER.
LIKE WAITING TO POUNCE AND YOU
FOR SAYING THE WRONG THING AND
WHICH IS THE WORST THING EVER.
TO MAKE PEOPLE TERRIFIED TO
THINK ABOUT SOMETHING.
ONLY TRUE TERROR TO HELP A
BLACKOUT IS WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED TO GIVE AN ANSWER LIKE
THAT.
>> WERE WERE TALKING ABOUT HIS
WE ALWAYS WORRY ABOUT THIS
EXTERNAL CENSORSHIP BUT NOW IT'
INTERNAL CENSORSHIP.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT THE ARTICL
WAS IN THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
SUCTION.
THERE WAS NOTHING HELP THE
ORWELL ABOUT THAT.
AS YOU READ THIS ARTICLE YOU GE
STUPIDER.
I WAS TRULY KNOW MYSELF AND
TRYING TO PEEL A BANANA BACK.
SO NOT ONLY IS TO DEFINE WHAT A
WOMAN IS UNDOABLE, IT ALSO IS
APPARENTLY BRACES.
SO THEY FOUND A WAY TO LINK THI
ONE.
SO BACK WHEN BRACES SOME WAS
FASHIONABLE AND YOU WENT SHARIN
BATHROOMS, YOU WOULD BE VERY
CLEAR ON WHAT BATHROOM AND THEY
SENT WHITE WOMEN ONLY, NOT BLAC
WOMEN, SO THEREFORE THEY FOR
SAYING THAT BLACK WOMEN FOR
WOMEN AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY,
NO, THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THEY WERE
WOMEN.
THEY JUST DIDN'T WANT BLACK
RACISM WAS ABOUT THE COLOR OF
SKIN AND THEY DIDN'T CARE IF
THEY WERE PACKING OVARIES ARE
NOT.
>> PACKING OVARIES.
>> OVARIES WERE ALWAYS WITH YOU.
>> YOU WOULDN'T KNOW.
IF I'M PACKING A GUN, IT IS ON
ME.
THAT IS WHAT IT MEANS.
>> BEFORE THE SHOW YOU TOLD ME
YOU WERE IN AND YOU ARE ACCEPTE
AND I'M SURE YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN INTERESTING MESSAGE.
YOU'RE YOUR BACK TO FOLK MUSIC.
ON BEHALF OF MEN EVERYWHERE TO
THE PEOPLE, EXTERNAL PEOPLE WHO